[Musique]
bonjour à tous depuis le 16 juin dernier
les députés de la commission d' enquête
consacrée aux qu'ovide 19 auditionnent
les acteurs de cette crise sanitaire
monde médical anciens ministres anciens
directeurs généraux de la santé tout
l'été lcp vous propose de revivre ces
auditions aujourd'hui celle de karine
lacombe chef de service des maladies
infectieuses à l'hôpital saint-antoine à
paris au menu masque vaccin traitement
mais aussi controverse autour de
l'hydroxyde chloroquine le traitement
défendue par le professeur didier rahout
pendant la crise les deux les deux
scientifiques se sont opposés sur ce
traitement
on écoute tout de suite karine lacombe
nous recevons aujourd'hui madame karine
lacombe avec laquelle nous avons
souhaité prolonger les thématiques
abordées hier avec le professeur out
madame la professeure après la maîtrise
de l'épidémie grâce confinement l effort
de tous les français que nous devons
saluer nous sommes entrés dans une
nouvelle phase de gestion de l'épidémie
qui a aussi celle qui est aussi celle du
bilan des semaines passées des
enseignements en tirer pour les mois à
venir
1 le professeur je vais vous donner la
parole pour un cours propos liminaire
l'intérêt étant évidemment les changes
avec les parlementaires
merci bien sûr merci beaucoup
madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les députés c'est
un honneur pour moi de porter devant
vous ma parole de soignants temple qui a
été en première ligne de front de
l'épidémie de kobe de 19 à l'hôpital et
je m'exprime également en tant que
chercheuse de la communauté de ceux et
celles qui ont un temps record
on se sont mobilisés pour construire le
corpus de connaissances dont nous avions
besoin pour soigner nos malades et je
m'exprime également en tant que femme
une d'entre celles qui comme moi mère
enseignante ont fait face pour assurer
nos missions de support de soutien et de
réassurance avec l'humanité est la
bienveillance dont chacun a besoin en
période critique et beaucoup se
reconnaîtront dans mon propos je suis
médecins infectiologues professeur à la
faculté de médecine sorbonne universités
et depuis un an chef de service des
maladies infectieuses et tropicales à
l'hôpital saint-antoine à paris
l'ap-hp
de par ma double valence universitaire
je suis également chercheuse à
l'institut pierre louis d'épidémiologie
et de santé publique au sein de l'équipe
épidémiologique clinique et des maladies
virales chroniques à l'inserm
j'ai été formé à la faculté de médecine
de grenoble et j'ai suivi à paris à
bordeaux un double cursus de santé
publique d'une part socialisée dans
l'évaluation des interventions santé et
d'infectiologie d'autre part avec un
focus sur les virus responsables
d'infections chroniques j'ai construit
toute ma carrière scientifique nationale
et internationale dans le domaine du vih
et des hépatites virales b et c et en
menant des études de cohorte et des
essais thérapeutiques en france mais
également dans les pays du sud comme le
vietnam la côte d'ivoire le sénégal le
bénin où le cameroun j'ai acquis des
compétences en recherche clinique et en
évaluation thérapeutique qui m'ont amené
à être sollicité pour participer en tant
qu'experte aux travaux de l' oms de
l'onu sida mais également d'institutions
comme le medicines patent pool qui
s'occupe de l'accès aux traitements
innovants pour les pays du sud en termes
de génériques jeu l'un d'eux l'un de mes
thèmes principaux de travail a été
l'élimination d'hépatite c au sein des
populations clés comme les usagers de
drogues et les hommes ayant des
relations sexuelles avec les hommes
et je me suis particulièrement investi
ces dernières années dans la prévention
et le contrôle du vih dans les
populations vulnérables que représentent
les migrants les travailleuses et
travailleurs du sexe et tous groupes
victimes de discrimination ma prise de
fonction de chef de service il ya un an
a ajouté un bon travail de clinicienne
de chercheuse et enseignante la
dimension de gestion d'équipé de
construction de projets communs pour
l'amélioration de la santé de nos
patients et de la qualité de vie de nos
personnels la connaissance justement du
patient et du soin avec un focus très
clinique est une qualité fondamentale
qui alimente la réflexion autour de la
recherche car je suis avant tout une
clinicienne et une épidémiologiste et en
parallèle enseigner m'a permis
d'acquérir de bons outils pédagogiques
pour délivrer les messages et adéquate
dans une période où l'anxiété
généralisée a été source
d'approximations et de conclusions
hâtives
or nous avons précisément besoin de
recul et de pédagogie pour faire passer
un message juste sans être trop
alarmiste ni trop rassurant
nous vivons une crise sanitaire majeure
qui ébranle nos conditions envers ce que
la science peut nous apporter et qui
fait trembler nos valeurs d'humanisme
d'entr'aide et de coopération
de nombreux débats scientifiques et
éthiques sont devenus des controverses
hasardeuse et des polémiques stériles et
ont masqué l'engagement de beaucoup
d'entre nous et envers nos malades et
ceux qui sont les plus fragiles mais je
tiens ici en me présentant devant vous à
témoigner pour notre communauté celle
des soignants du métier le plus modeste
au métier le plus prestigieux tous
exercé avec la même humilité la même
ardeur le même professionnalisme de ceux
qui ont travaillé sans discontinuer
comme ceux qui sont tombés malades
par leur engagement auprès des patients
je témoigne également pour les femmes
qui ont été au premier rang du caire
mais tellement sous représentées dans la
recherche sur le co vide comme dans les
médias comme si l'ombre nous convenait
en général plus que la lumière que plus
prosaïquement la charge mentale que nous
éprouvons en temps ordinaire est encore
plus lourde en temps de crise et nous a
imposé de faire des choix mais sachez
que le patient a toujours été au coeur
des choix que nous avons fait que ce
soit des choix de soins des choix de
traitements ou des choix
d'accompagnement et nous avons nous
toutes et tous fait le choix du soin et
de la recherche dans l'intérêt du plus
grand nombre en faisant fi de notre
intérêt individuel
mon propos liminaires et volontairement
court car je souhaite laisser l'espace à
vos questions et tenter d'apporter de la
place qui est la mienne issues du
terrain et chef d'equipe l'éclairage
dont vous pouvez avoir besoin sur la
gestion de la crise du coït 19 à
l'hôpital et dans les unités de
recherche
merci merci beaucoup madame avant de
passer la parole au rapporteur j'ai deux
questions préliminaires
pouvez vous nous faire le point sur la
situation de l'épidémie aujourd'hui et
votre après ça votre appréciation sur le
risque d'une deuxième vague dont on nous
parle avec dans des degrés différents
et la deuxième chose pour faire suite à
notre édition d'hier
à la fin du mois de mars vous avait
fortement critiqué les essais cliniques
menés par le professeur out sur les
docks cycle origines associés
l'antibiotique pouvez vous indiquer pour
quelles raisons vous avez estimé que ce
traitement pouvait être
dangereux pour les passions et quelle
appréciation portez vous sur les autres
essais cliniques menés par le professeur
out
voilà les deux questions j'avais à vous
poser ce matin très bien merci madame la
présidente alors le point sur l'épidémie
je pense que tout le monde a vu les
données qui sont publiés de façon au
moins hebdomadaire par le santé publique
france actuellement on peut dire que
l'épidémie de l'ampleur qu'elle a eu en
mars avril et contrôler ce qui ne veut
pas dire que le virus a disparu qu'il
n'y a plus de mal and le virus est
toujours là on le voit bien parce qu'il
ya de nombreux cluster qu'ils sont
dépistés diagnostic est quasi tous les
jours en france mais ça veut aussi dire
que les outils de dépistage qui ont été
mis en place sont effectifs que le fait
que l'on puisse des pistes et des
personnes malades et que l'on dépiste
surtout les personnes asymptomatiques
qui ont été au contact de ces personnes
malades et qu on les isole permet de
contenir la diffusion de l'épidémie
qu'est ce qu'il en est du futur
alors vous savez comme moi que le les
connaissances sur le coronavirus le sar
sco b 2 se sont accumulées depuis cinq
mois et on peut dire que c'est une
période extrêmement courte pour savoir
exactement comment ce virus va se
comporter dans les mois à venir
ce virus fait partie de la famille de
plusieurs coronavirus on en connaît
quatre qui étaient jusqu'à présent des
virus banale qui donnait des rhumes et
qui étaient eux saisonnier mais
saisonniers en fait en circulant autour
de entre l'hémisphère nord et
l'hémisphère sud il existe un virus qui
a disparu encore navires us lorsque
objets qui lui a disparu après une
épidémie en 2002-2003 qui a fait sept ou
huit cents morts et on en a un sixième
qui est le maire sco b qui lui touche le
moyen-orient et qui évolue par épidémie
sporadiques
donc vous voyez le sarko v2 est le
sixième virus de cette famille et vous
voyez que chacun de ces virus a quasi
une évolution qui est différente
donc il est très difficile en l'état
actuel des connaissances de se demander
si ce virus est saisonnier s'il va
disparaître ou s'il va y avoir une vraie
deuxième vague une troisième une
quatrième
terra j'espère que d'ici là on aura
trouvé des thérapeutiques et surtout des
traitements préventifs contre des
vaccins qui seront efficaces qui
concerne les essais sur la chloroquine
alors je veux vraiment vous dire devant
vous que je ne me suis pas opposé à
quelques scientifiques que ce soit je
pense que mes parents l'ont été assez
clair et je me suis exprimé à plusieurs
reprises à cette occasion dans les
médias je ne me suis pas non plus
exposés à une molécule
j'ai simplement essayé d'apporter un
regard critique ce qui fait partie de
toute démarche scientifique sur la façon
dont un essai pouvait être fait une
étude observationnelle ou un essai
interventionnelle il est très important
quand on porte une conclusion qui peut
avoir un impact majeur en termes de
santé publique d'avoir des données qui
sont solides avec de nombreux confrères
à partir du mois de mars
nous avons émis des remarques sur la
façon dont les essais qui prône l
utilisation massive la chloroquine avait
été fait je vous rappelle que il y à des
données in vitro qui montre que
l'hydroxyde chloroquine est efficace
compte un très grand nombre de virus a
été montré pour la dengue le chikungunya
le sar sco vais mais également le sarko
v2 ces données sont solides c'est de l'
in vitro dans le laboratoire il sa
personne n'a remis en question
l'efficacité de l'hydroxyde chloroquine
sur le sarko v2 mais comme sur beaucoup
d'autres virus
évidemment il était très important à
l'époque où l'épidémie a émergé donc en
février/mars de voir quels médicaments
pourraient être utilisés pour traiter le
sarko v2 étant donné qu' on ne pouvait
que repositionner des molécules qui
existait déjà puisque la recherche
n'avait pas encore eu le temps de
développer des molécules qui était
spécifique du sart sco b 2 parmi toutes
ces molécules hydroxy chloroquine était
une des molécules à l'aisselle le
problème pour poser les essais qui ont
été menées par les personnes qui ont
prôné très rapidement le
l'utilisation de l'hydroxyde chloroquine
c'est que après des essais avec un très
petit effectif
méthodologiquement contestable et je
peux revenir sur ces questions
méthodologiques
il y a eu un espoir prématurée un espoir
prématurée parce que beaucoup de
personnes ont cru que le remède miracle
était là si on rapporte
si si je vous remet un peu en
perspective ce qu'il s'est passé en mars
il y a eu d'abord une première étude de
20 patients puis une une deuxième étude
de 80 patients qui ont été publiées dont
on a les résultats on peut discuter des
résultats qui ont été mis à la
disposition du public
et puis ensuite il ya eu une étude 1000
patients 3700 passion qui ont été
dépistés et 1000 patients qui sont qui
sont rapportés dans un texte qui n'est
pas publié
donc on n'a pas pu savoir qui étaient
ces 1000 patients comment le traitement
leur avait été donné à ce qu'ils étaient
arrivés
est-ce qu'ils étaient arrivés à l'issue
du traitement le et dès que dès que ces
traitements dès que c'est les deux
premiers essais celui de 20 et celui de
87 patients ont été publiés il y a eu
une captation du débat public du débat
scientifique par un discours médiatique
qui a empêché complètement tout débat
scientifique d'être mené à son terme
je vais juste vous rappeler jeu je pense
que beaucoup d'entre vous entendu
puisque beaucoup de choses en circuler
sur les réseaux sociaux donc je me
permet de rapporter l'interview peu
alain fischer qui est professeur au
collège de france et dans son discours
de clôture a bien reparler de tout
l'immunologie du sar sauvé 2 alain
fischer a rappelé que c'était que la
démarche scientifique
on a une hypothèse on mène ensuite une
expérience ensuite on soumet cette
expérience à la validation critique et
alors qu'il aurait fallu qu'il y ait un
débat scientifique et que l'on discute
ensemble pour voir quelles étaient les
limites méthodologiques et qu'ensuite on
puisse construire ensemble les essais
qu'ils pouvaient répondre à la question
ce débat était clos et à partir de ce
jour là nous n'avons plus jamais pu
débattre sereinement et je pense que la
science a été extrêmement malmené dans
cette
dans ce contexte alors on peut
maintenant revenir sur les chiffres il a
été reproché en particulier à l'île de
france et c'est vrai que nous avons nous
médecins étaient très sensibles à ces
critiques qu'il y avait une mortalité
très élevé en ile de france et que dans
d'autres régions hydroxyque l'euro qui
n'avait pu être utilisées à plus large
échelle la mortalité était beaucoup plus
faible alors évidemment c'est faux c'est
faux par exemple il ya des régions en
france qui n'ont pas utilisé les drogues
cycle rockin il n'y a eu aucun décès
mais effectivement en ile de france il
faut vraiment faire attention la
différence entre la létalité la
mortalité
il y a eu beaucoup de confusion entre
les deux je vous rappelle que la
létalité c'est le nombre de morts parmi
les personnes malades et la mortalité
c'est le nombre de morts en population
générale et nous avons maintenant des
données solides méthodologiquement bien
construite qui montre que à crépy en
valois dans les personnes dans l'est la
population qui a été en contact avec ce
collègue professeur qui est décédé l'un
des premiers cas qui a alerté l'opinion
publique
dans cette étude il a été le la
prévalence est à dire le nombre de cas
positifs au sein scovell de a été évalué
par sérologie et si je vous rappelle les
chiffres pour être prêts précise le taux
d' attaque c'est à dire le nombre de
personnes qui ont contracté le sarko
veut d'eux était de 25% ce qui n'est pas
négligeable
la létalité comme la mortalité était de
0 % c'est à dire que dans une population
naïve de virus naïfs de traitement la
mortalité ou la létalité est extrêmement
faible
c'est exactement les données qui ont été
retrouvés en population générale dans
les régions on a été tenté de prescrire
plus d'ide roxy chloroquine actuellement
je pense mais on peut en débattre que la
question de l'efficacité de l'hydroxyde
chloroquine chez les personnes qui
présentent des symptômes nécessitant une
hospitalisation est clos on a des essais
thérapeutiques en particulier laisser
recovery en angleterre laisser discovery
qui est je vous rappelle est un essai
fille de qu'aux grands essais solidarity
de l'om est ce avec un grand nombre de
patients ont montré que quand on compare
un groupe qui reçoit une prise en charge
standard il n'y a pas de d'efficacité
démontrée de l'hydroxyde chloroquine
comme à ce jour il n'ya pas d'efficacité
démontrée de n'importe quel autre
traitement on peut tout à fait revenir
sur ce point là donc je peux dire
qu'actuellement
malheureusement nous n'avons pas encore
de traitement qui a fait ses preuves
chez les patients qui ont des signes de
gravité c'est à dire qui nécessitent
d'être hospitalisé
si je peux continuer sur le sujet des
drogues si chloroquine l'autre question
qui était extrêmement intéressante
c'était de savoir s'il hydroxy
chloroquine pouvait être un traitement
prophylactique c'est-à-dire un
traitement préventif de l'infection par
le sarko v2 et là aussi on a une grande
étude qui a été menée aux états unis qui
a été publié il ya une dizaine de jours
et qui montre qu' il n'y a pas d'effet
prophylactique nous d'effet préventif de
l'hydroxyde chloroquine chez les
personnes qui sont exposées au sart sco
b 2 évidemment tout le monde et moi la
première en tant que soignante chef de
service qui a travaillé avec mes équipes
dans des dans un hôpital où nous avons
été submergés de patients coville 19
nous aurions aimé avoir une molécule qui
marche qui soigne qui guérit nos
patients
actuellement ce n'est pas le cas
j'espère que dans les semaines à venir
alors que nous allons avoir les
résultats de nouveaux essais
thérapeutiques nous pourrons avoir des
molécules repositionner qui marcherait
mais je fais surtout le pari pour des
molécules à venir qui elles sont
vraiment dirigé contre le sarko v2 qui
vont intervenir vont interférer
pleinement avec le cycle de réplication
virale peut-être des molécules et
peut-être qu'on aura l'occasion d'y
revenir comme le plasma les
immunoglobulines spécifique du virus ou
voir des anticorps monoclonaux
spécifique du virus émergeront dans les
mois à venir et j'espère avant une
éventuelle deuxième vague comme on en a
parlé tout à l'heure
merci monsieur le rapporteur
mais merci madame le professeur vous
nous avez apporté des explications
je voudrais revenir quelques instants
sur le le sentiment qu'on peut nourrir
en n'étant pas professionnel ou qu'a pu
ressentir la population nos
concitoyennes devant ces conflits
d'experts et quelque part vous en avez
été un peu d acteurs médiatiques qui ont
opposé des médecins et des chercheurs et
qui ont tourné quelques fois une forme
de confusion pour laquelle il est très
difficile de ceux de se retrouver qui
ont donné le sentiment alors que nous
étions confrontés à une crise d'une
ampleur terrifiante avec une inquiétude
majeure dans la population que certains
aient été mobilisés dans une forme de
querelles mais au-delà de ce sentiment
qui est quand même assez regrettable
il y as peut-être et je voudrais avoir
votre avis là-dessus
une problématique liée à la multiplicité
des études cliniques et pas simplement
en france qui ont été faites notamment
sur la question de l'hydroxyde
chloroquine mais peut-être sur d'autres
traitements
certains de vos confrères on parler
d'épidémie de recherche devant nos
collègues sénateurs
je cite dominique costagliola qui a
regretté la multiplication des c'est
parfois concurrents sans coordination
comment on pourrait arriver selon vous à
normaliser un peu ces essais c'est qu'il
ya pas d'autorisation d'une instance
reconnue pour ce type ce type d'essai
mais comment vous voyez est ce qu'il est
nécessaire selon vous qui a une forme de
régulation de normalisation pour que et
bien c'est ses querelles pour beaucoup
nous dépasse ils sont difficiles à
apprécier
quand on n'est pas expert et j'ai
l'impression même pour les experts vu
leur la la virulence de leurs
argumentaires de leur argumentation
comment vous en tant que professionnel
vous voyez cette cette évolution qui
peut-être peut-être qui peut être une
conséquence de la crise
ensuite bon sur ce débat sur la
chloroquine c'est un débat qui a été vif
dans notre pays mais c'est aussi une
problématique internationale
comment elle est traitée ailleurs
puisque on nous a dit et je sais pas si
et je soumets à votre vérification en
tout cas votre appréciation
cette cette approche aussi que c'est un
traitement qui aujourd'hui est diffusée
sur la moitié de la planète et qui est
utilisé en traitement sur une population
de 4 milliards et demi de personnes donc
bon à tendance et c'est un peu notre
tempérament
regardez d'abord ce qui se passe chez
nous mais c'est aussi une problématique
internationale qui pour le coup
relativise peut-être un peu le débat
français
je vous remercie
c'est beaucoup pour votre question alors
effectivement je suis d'accord avec vous
et avec dominique costagliola pour dire
qu'il ya eu une inflation des ces
thérapeutiques en france si par exemple
on prend le ce qui s'est passé en
angleterre donc en angleterre il ya un
seul gros essais thérapeutiques qui
s'appelle solidarity avec cinq bras de
traitement dont l'idh roxy chloroquine
qui a été arrêté et mes collègues
anglais avec lesquels j'ai beaucoup de
relations au quotidien nous ont dit nous
on nous a interdit de faire d'autres
essais thérapeutiques on a fait un seul
essai gros essais on a effectivement
inclut 11 mille patients et c'est
l'essai qui va permettre de répondre par
exemple à l'efficacité du lopinavir
ritonavir qui a déjà répondu à la
question de l'efficacité de la
dexaméthasone sous corticoïdes qui est
efficace quand on a des signes
importants de kovy de 19 en particulier
pulmonaire qui teste également d'autres
médicaments sur lesquels on pourra
revenir si vous le souhaitez et c'est
vrai que et le plasma pendant ses
clients j'allais l'oublier alors que
c'est le type d'essai que je baise moi
même en france c'est un gros avantage
évidemment c'est que on a pu dans une
seule direction mettre tous les
chercheurs en ordre de bataille et testé
cinq hypothèses le système anglais est
extrêmement différent du nôtre
vous savez qu'un médecin ne peut pas
prescrire des médicaments qu'il veut si
par exemple je me réfère au vih le
médecin qui en face de lui un patient
infecté par le vih ne peut pas lui
prescrire le traitement qu'il pense être
le plus adapté à son cas
il doit suivre obligatoirement les
recommandations nationales les
recommandations nationales ne sont pas
toujours basé uniquement sur le bien du
patient mais également sur des questions
de coût ce qui peut parfois obérer le
meilleur soin que l'on pourrait apporter
aux patients on savait qu'en france ce
n'est pas l'option qui a été prise en
france nous sommes relativement libre
dans nos prescriptions dans le cadre de
la m
et si on sort de là mêmes et bien il
faut le justifier mais dans tous les cas
il y a rarement d
des actions qui sont entreprises contre
les médecins qui ont prescrit un
médicament oreilles mais le et le
principe de la recherche était est
exactement le même c'est à dire que le
chercheur est libre de mener l'essai
thérapeutique il souhaite à partir du
moment où il a des arguments
scientifiques scientifiquement valides
qui lui permettent d'avoir le budget
nécessaire pour mener son projet de
recherche
peut-être si je devais aller dans votre
sens dans une crise telle que celle
qu'on l'a connu une articulation
centrale très précoce des de la
recherche clinique
le choix des traitements et une
imposition sur l'ensemble du territoire
d'un essai thérapeutique globale aurait
peut-être permis de répondre plus
rapidement aux questions que l'on se
posait je pense que surtout quand on
repositionne des molécules dans une
épidémie on sait qu'en général en deux
mois
l' affaire est réglée et c'est vrai que
la recherche le temps de la recherche
c'est pas le temps médiatique et que
souvent quand le temps médiatique prend
le pas sur le temps de la recherche et
bien on peut arriver comme vous dites à
une certaine confusion
le donc ça c'était pour le premier plan
je voulais revenir juste sur un mot que
vous avez prononcé acteurs médiatiques
je peux dire également que j'ai été
victime médiatique puisque vous vous
devez proment savoir que suite à mes
prises de position sur les méthodes j'ai
été menacé de mort et j'ai porté plainte
et je trouve que c'est extrêmement
dommageable pour la science de d'avoir à
subir les feux médiatiques de ce type là
jean pierre door pour les républicains
merci madame la présidente eu avec
plaisir la première première
intervention
oui madame merci de vos de votre
présentation
on vous connaît je vous ai connu
particulièrement pour les travaux sur
l'hépatite c
voilà simplement quelques remarques
les essais cliniques en france socom
doivent être déclarés et régulé donc on
est on passe en dehors de ce système là
ou pas c'est une des questions
normalement c'est déclaré donc
pour les expériences dont vous parlez
des de certains produits non déclarés ça
pose problème alors que les autres
questions vous avez fait volte face à un
moment pour l'utilisation des masques
web bien savoir pourquoi
étant donné que les masses sont une
protection indispensable de soi et des
autres
donc c'était étonnant quand j'ai vu que
vous aviez effectivement vous avez fait
volte-face et maintenant vous accepter
qu'on s'en serve comme mesures barrières
moi j'ai des questions à vous poser
hier nous avons eu la notion de conflit
d'intérêts avec une grande entreprise
américaine gilead d'ailleurs gilles yade
qui faisait partie des médicaments
d'hépatite c
qu'est ce que vous pensez il ya un
communiqué paru ce matin
oui hier soir des scientifiques des
chercheurs pour contester un ce genre de
truc donc ce sera intéressant vous nous
en parler
et puis enfin deux points qu'est ce que
vous pensez du traitement par la d'exams
états zone qui est partie comme
stéroïdiens et puis que pensez-vous du
vaccin puisque ce matin l'entreprise
moderna a dit qu'ils étaient peut-être
prêt pour la fin de l'année est ce que
ça peut être vrai est-ce que c'est pas
encore un effet d'annonce dont il
faudrait se méfier
merci merci beaucoup monsieur le député
alors je vais tout d'abord vous répondre
sur la partie éthique des essais je suis
entièrement d'accord avec vous tous les
essais thérapeutiques depuis le procès
de nuremberg gain de 1945 demande à ce
qu'il y ait des déclarations préalables
déclarations préalables qui ne sont pas
faites par rapport au traitement
lui-même et par rapport à la personne
par rapport à la personne qui se prête à
la recherche clinique et en particulier
pour sauvegarder le droit de la personne
et
c'est son intégrité physique il est
extrêmement important quand on analyse
quand on évalue un nouveau médicament ou
un médicament dans une autre indication
que celle pour laquelle il a été mis sur
le marché que ce soit encadré sur le
plan éthique
tous les essais thérapeutiques que nous
menons particulier si je peux parler
pour moi ce que je mène ont suivi la
procédure éthiques habituelles c'est à
dire que quand c'est un essai qui
implique un nouveau médicament qui
implique la personne humaine et qui est
prospectifs c'est à dire que l'on ne
travaille pas sur des données que l'on a
déjà recueilli mais qui est prospectifs
on va recueillir les données au fur et à
mesure de l'essai on doit déclarer ses
essais au comité de protection des
personnes
comité de protection des personnes
maintenant est indépendant des instituts
puisqu'il se puisque les essais sont
attribués au cpp par par un tirage au
sort ce qui permet d'avoir tout de même
une certaine individualités par rapport
à laisser aux promoteurs qui est la
personne qui est là le responsable moral
de l'essai à l'investigateur qui est la
personne qui construit l'essai et aux
financeurs je suppose que votre question
fêterait ses allusions des points
éthique que l'on a pu soulever par
rapport aux essais qui ont été menées
sur la chloroquine c'est vrai que nous
sommes beaucoup posé la question de la
démarche éthique et en particulier du
respect du droit des personnes
dans les essais qui ont été enlevés par
les tout à leur laisser de 26 passion et
l'essai de 87 patients sans même parler
de la cohorte de mille patients puisque
nous n'avons pas accès aux données
s'il devait y avoir un contrôle éthique
ce n'est pas à moi de le fermer aux
instances de régulation que sont la nes
m donc je ne me prononcerai pas sur le
le le fait que ces essais aient été
autorisées par les autorités tic
compétentes
probablement que si il y à une
interrogation qui persiste et c'est vrai
que nous scientifiques nous avons
soulevé ce problème en mars
c'est aux autorités compétentes comme la
nsm de s'intéresser à la façon dont les
essais ont été menés en particulier si
le droit des personnes a été conservé
dans ces circonstances là alors quand
vous parlez de ma volte face par rapport
aux masques je pense que vous faites
allusion à une des interventions
médiatiques que j'ai pu avoir je ne sais
pas si vous avez entendu l'intégralité
de cette intervention médiatique je sais
que elle a été reprise sur les réseaux
sociaux mais vraiment dans une partie
très tronqué
quand j'ai parlé des masques nous étions
dans une période où nous étions très
contraint en termes d'accès aux masques
je dois dire qu'à l'hôpital
nous n'avons pas eu grâce à la façon
dont le peu de masques disponibles a été
géré nous n'avons pas eu de pénurie de
masques en revanche il y a eu une
pénurie de ma dans les établissements
médico-sociaux une pénurie de masques
chez les médecins généralistes les
médecins libéraux et puis évidemment une
pénurie de masques dans le grand public
1 quand on m'a posé la question de
l'utilisation des masques
je répondais spécifiquement sur quand on
est dans une dans une période
contraintes en termes de nombre de
masques disponibles qui devait
prioritairement à voir les masques je
profite justement de ce que vous venez
de dire sur un discours médiatique que
j'ai pu porter que ce qui a beaucoup
altérer notre discours de scientifiques
ça a été l'information immédiate la
façon dont par exemple les chaînes
d'information continue mais également
les réseaux sociaux ont pris des mini
portion de discours des mini images pour
justement appuyer ce qui allait aller
dans le sens du clic pour les réseaux
sociaux dans le sens du nombre de vues
pour les chaînes d'information continue
alors ensuite les les
mais les liens d'intérêts alors vraiment
vous avez employé le terme de conflit
d'intérêts le conflit d'intérêts c'est
une notion qui existait il y à 20 25 ans
qui a énormément fait de mal à la
science je suis issue d'une époque
ultérieure le
les liens d'intérêts c'est un dispositif
qui est qui qui a été voté par le
législateur ce n'est pas à vous que je
vais rappeler les lois la loi
anti-cadeaux savez la loi anti-cadeaux
l'ordonance 2017 49 du 19 janvier 2017
qui est relative aux avantages offerts
aux personnes par les personnes pardon
qui fabriquent commercialisent les
produits etc etc
cette loi est extrêmement importante
parce que l interdit ou professionnels
de santé les étudiants mais je me place
plutôt sur les professionnels de santé
de recevoir des avantages illicite de la
part des industriels du secteur de la
santé
il y à des dérogations ces dérogations
elles sont de trois types la
rémunération la démonisation ou le
défraiement d'activités de recherche de
valorisation de la recherche
d'évaluation scientifique de conseils
prestations de services etc
dès lors que la rémunération est
proportionné aux services rendus
les avantages perçus pour les étudiants
en médecine je n'en parle pas et
l'hospitalité offerte aux médecins dans
des manifestations à caractère
exclusivement professionnels et
scientifiques celi et ça c'est ce qu'on
appelle des liens d'intérêts le
d'ailleurs vous les connaissez s'il ya
un intérêt puisque le législateur a fait
en sorte que tout soit transparent
tout est dans la base de transparence
que vous connaissez tous que tout le
monde est aller la consulter
il faut savoir que les liens d'intérêts
sont régies de façon très stricte par
les professionnels de santé les
industriels le conseil de l'ordre et les
employés des professionnels de santé
je vais vous parler pour ma part donc je
suis professeur des universités je suis
payé par le ministère de l'enseignement
supérieur et je reçois des émoluments de
le de l'hôpital donc je ne suis pas
salarié de l'hôpital je suis pas salarié
de la fonction publique hospitalière je
reçois des émoluments quand un
industriel me demande une prestation le
type de prestation qui sont dans la base
de données de transparence sont en gros
de deux types
ça peut être des prestations d'experts
et certains confondues board avec
conseil d'administration un borgne n'est
pas un conseil d'administration il
fallait peut-être
dans le monde de la finance mais ça ne
l'est pas dans le monde de la médecine
donc je peux être interrogé en tant
qu'expert et on peut me demander en tant
qu'expert professeurs de faire de
l'enseignement à l'occasion d'une
conférence ou qui en général est
retransmise libres de droit et qui est
organisé par par l'industrie dans le
cadre de ces deux activités je peux
revenir sur chacune d'elles nous avons
des frais tout professionnel par exemple
quelqu'un qui travaille dans la banque
elkin qui fait des missions de
consulting et c'est à partir du moment
où il est mandaté par la personne qui le
payent pour faire cette mission à son
repas pris en charge éventuellement son
transport et éventuellement son biais de
son son hôtel c'est ce qu'on appelle des
avantages en nature mais c'est des
avantages en nature dans le cadre d'une
mission
si ensuite je reviens sur la façon dont
ses liens d'intérêt sont encadrées par
la loi
quand un professionnel de l'industrie
mme propose une prestation que ce soit
d'experte ou de conférencière nous
rédigeons un contrat
ce contrat est envoyé à mon employeur
qui est l'université l'université me
demandent enfin je demande pardon un
cumul d'activités à l'université
l'université donne son accord ou pas ce
sur quoi l'université se base pour
donner son accord c'est qu'elle regarde
la rémunération la rémunération fx n'est
pas libre cette rémunération est un
montant brut en général horaires et
l'université dit ok le travail qui est
demandé correspond bien à 2h 3h 4h de
travail je donne en autorisation de
cumul ensuite est autorisé à son cumul
est validée par l'hôpital l'hôpital
donne son autorisation et ensuite cette
convention avec l'autorisation de ces
deux institutions est envoyé au conseil
de l'ordre et le conseil de l'ordre ont
dernier ressort son avis est consultatif
mais il dit oui
j'autorise ou non je n'autorise pas et
ensuite le législateur a fait en sorte
que toutes ces données soient dans une
base de transparence donc je pense que
le lien d'intérêt en france est vraiment
très encadré le pourquoi il est
important quand on est un scientifique
d'avoir des liens d'intérêts ils n'ont
pas des conflits sage
si sts bien et je pense que maintenant
en tout cas dans les domaines
d'expertisé dans lesquels je travaille
il n'y a plus de conflits d'intérêts
pourquoi c'est important d'avoir un lien
d'intérêt parce que il y à des molécules
innovantes des mois que les véhicules et
innovantes qui sont développées par des
biotech des start up qui ensuite n'ont
pas les moyens de commercialiser alors
de continuer le développement de ses
molécules parce que vous parliez tout à
l'heure de l'hépatite c et pour
développer un médicament innovant dans
l'hépatite c qui a été une vraie
révolution dans l'hépatite c est ce que
ça permet de guérir des patients qui par
ailleurs avait des infections chroniques
avec beaucoup de co mobilité maintenant
tout le monde connaît ce terme est bien
il a fallu des milliards et des
milliards de dollars d'euros pour
développer ce médicament évidemment une
boîte de biotech de start up n'a pas
l'argent pour faire ce développement
donc souvent ces molécules sont rachetés
par les industriels ensuite les
industriels vont développer ses
médicaments le fait d'avoir de
travailler en collaboration avec les
industriels nous permet nous avant que
le médicament ne soit mise sur le marché
d'avoir accès à ces traitements
innovants pour nos patients par exemple
je reviens sur l'hépatite c
nous avons pu avoir accès à de nombreux
maîtres de médicaments innovants ont
permis de guéret l'hépatite c
alors je m'arrête pour sur les conflits
d'intérêts on pourra y revenir si vous
souhaitez rapidement sur les corticoïdes
évidemment c'est une très bonne question
les corticoïdes dans l'essai sol il
solidarity qui avait donc inclus un
grand nombre de patients n'a pu montrer
que les corticoïdes versus la prise en
charge standard était plus efficace et
diminuer d'un tiers la mortalité chez
les personnes qui étaient les plus
malades et de 1/5 chez celles qui
étaient un peu moins malade c'est un bon
médicament
c'est un médicament qui est tellement
beau que nous en france dans les
hôpitaux en particulier dans l'hôpital
dans lequel je travaille mais pas le
seul
chez les malades qui étaient gravement
affecter gravement symptomatique du coc
u19 nous avons utilisé les corticoïdes
les corticoïdes sont une sont un
traitement qui était déjà utilisée dans
les infections virales à fort expression
inflammatoires donc nous avons utilisé
les corticoïdes et je pense que des
malades ont été sauvés grâce aux
corticoïdes
ce qui est très important et solidarity
c'est que
ça l'a montré de façon non attaquable
sur le plan scientifique
ensuite le vaccin pour finir sur le
vaccin
je suis d'accord avec vous je pense
qu'il ya eu beaucoup d'effets d'annoncé
sur les vaccins probablement pour
augmenter les levées de fonds parce que
pour développer une molécules innovantes
dans un temps record il faut avoir
beaucoup d'argent et 15 et qu'un
producteur de vaccins qui ne va pas
faire d'effet d'annoncé bien
probablement aura moins de levée de
fonds de ce dont il a besoin pour
développer un vaccin non plus de
plusieurs questions sur le lien
d'intérêts et conflits et conflits
d'intérêts je veux dire que la nuance a
pas été vraiment fait dans ce qui nous a
été dit hier
j'aimerais savoir quelle est
l'appréciation vous portez sur la
compétence et l'indépendance dans la
crise du conseil scientifique et de ses
membres de la chasse et de la haute
autorité santé et de l' agence du
médicament
et je voudrais savoir si avoir un lien
d'intérêt prédispose avant dé préférence
pour tel ou tel traitement avec
développées par l'industrie avec
laquelle on aurait cessé les intérêts ça
c'est ma première question pour
compléter la réponse que vous avez
apporté mettre ma deuxième question elle
elle concerne vos équipes qu une
question simple comment vont vos
collaboratrice et vos collaborateurs
est ce que vous pourriez nous dire ce
qui a été leur quotidien si ils ont été
exposés et surtout de quoi vous avez
manqué il nous dira si selon votre
appréciation c'est l'hôpital où les
soignants qui ont tenu je crois ne pas
avoir entendu beaucoup parler d'eux
d'études sur leur md y virent pas
beaucoup en tout cas beaucoup moins que
l'hydroxyde chloroquine finalement donc
je voulais avoir votre avis là-dessus et
puis reprendre une pour et ma dernière
question reprendre vos affirmations
c'est vrai que vous disiez c'est un
virus inconnu avec une physiopathologie
sans exemple jusqu alors et vous avez
vous l'avez déjà tout le talent a redit
vous nous avez dit finalement dans un
article que j'ai pu lire vous disiez
finalement on a eu peu d'informations de
la chine probablement peut-être avec des
informations erronées et nous avons mis
en place tout ce qu'on pouvait à partir
du moment où on a une vision assez
claire et objective en italie voilà un
petit peu sur quoi nous expliquer le
déroulé merci merci qui surpasse la
parole professeurs c'est évident que on
avait comme je l' ai dit tout à l'heure
tous envie d'avoir un médicament
rapidement disponibles on pouvait
montrer qu'ils marchaient le problème et
je pense l'avoir dit peut-être pas assez
clairement c'est que dire qu'un
médicament
celui ci est pas un autre marche et le
répéter sur les réseaux sociaux et dire
vous devez prendre ce médicament vous
devez prendre ce médicament fait émerger
un sentiment de sentiments d'espoir
d'espoir le problème de l'espoir c'est
que quand il est touché comme ça se
passe maintenant que des gens qui
peut-être n'était pas très malades sont
décédés d'avoir pris de la chloroquine
il y en a
s'armer quand même les choses à leur
juste valeur quand on est médecin notre
rôle c'est primum non nocere et on ne
doit avant tout pas faire de tort donner
un médicament efficace c'est toujours
une balance bénéfices risques que j'ai
entendu ce mot tout à l'heure une
balance bénéfices risques primum non
nocere est vraiment dans le cadre
d'essais cliniques où on inclut un grand
nombre de patients et nos collègues de
marseille avait la possibilité de le
faire puisqu'ils ont dépisté 3500
patients 3500 patients c'est beaucoup on
peut facilement dans cette dans cette
configuration
faire un essai qui permet de voir si
prendre hydroxy chloroquine versus la
prise en charge standard fait bien mais
ça n'a pas été fait pourquoi ce n'est
pas à moi de répondre s'il devait y
avoir une commission indépendante sur la
façon dont les essais ont été faits je
pense que c'est une question qui va
falloir adressé le vous dit ensuite un
point important nous sommes actuellement
en incapacité de bien tester les
clusters alors je me permets de vous
contredire
je pense que c'était le cas en février
mars quand nous n'avions pas les tests
actuellement nous avons les tests les
tests sont largement disponibles test de
pcr on peut quand une personne a des
symptômes évoquant échos gide
le diagnostic est justement lâcher la
nuance entre le diagnostic et le
dépistage le diagnostic c'est quand
quelqu'un est malade et ensuite le but
de tester les clusters c'est de dépister
les personnes alentour qui sont
asymptomatiques et ensuite de les isoler
cette stratégie de d2 diagnostic
dépistage isolement des clusters doit
être fait à grande échelle
j'espère qu'avec des structures comme ce
qui a été mise en place avec les caisses
d'assurance maladie
le système comme ihsan à paris par
exemple mais il ya des systèmes
équivalents en région on va pouvoir
justement identifier ces clusters et je
pense que les chiffres de santé publique
france soutiennent cette vérité là
un autre point important j'ai été sévère
avec le professeur raoul tu as la
conférence de presse du premier ministre
alors et j'ai parlé de discovery alors
en fait je pense que vous confondez avec
ma collègue florence ader qui a fait la
deuxième conférence de presse à propos
des traitements
j'ai moi même fait la première
conférence de presse le 28 mars
on m'a appelé la veille le 27 mars
vendredi 27 mars et on m'a demandé si
j'acceptais de participer à cette
conférence de presse je dois dire que je
n'avais eu aucun contact avec le
ministère de la santé le ministre de la
santé est encore plus la présidence dans
les jours qui précédaient
on doit d'un appel d'olivier ferrand qui
a appelé beaucoup de médecins pour en
fait savoir comment ça se passait à
l'hôpital on échange qui a durée de 3
minutes et voilà est effectivement le 27
le vendredi 27 mars
on m'a appelé pour le lendemain
participer à la conférence de presse
pour parler de la virologie donc le
l'épidémiologie la virologie et
l'histoire naturelle c'est-à-dire les
manifestations cliniques du virus c'est
la conférence de presse qui est de
quelques semaines plus tard à laquelle a
participé ma collègue de lyon le
professeur ader qui est investigatrice
principal de l'essai discovery qui elle
a parlé de discovery et je ne veux pas
me prononcer pour elle mais il ne me
semble pas qu'elle ait attaqué le
professeur raout mais voilà alors le
plasma très très intéressant
effectivement c'est une thérapeutique
éprouvée qui a été utilisé dans beaucoup
de maladies infectieuses qui parfois un
marché qui parfois n'a pas marché par
exemple le plasma de patients
convalescent dans ebola n'a pas marché
le plasma de convalescent dans le sahara
sco v2 nous l'avons mis en place en
france
l'essai thérapeutique parce que il là il
y a eu des cohortes de patients petit
nombre de patients qui ont été traités
de cette manière en chine et on avait le
sentiment que ça marchait nous avons
donc monté un essai thérapeutique
déclaré en cpp avec du multicentrique
neuf centres exactement qui peuvent
inclure dans cet essai donc nous avons
inclus des patients je peux pas vous en
donner de résultats puisque l'essai est
encore en cours
nous allons ouvrir un centre à mayotte
et surtout nous allons ouvrir un centre
à cayenne un centre en guyane où on voit
que l'épidémie fait rage et que le pic
de l'épidémie ne se rapprocheront pas
atteint avant la fin du mois de juillet
il est donc indispensable d'apporter une
solution thérapeutique à nos collègues
de guyane en revanche là où nous avons
actuellement des données intéressantes
sur le plasma c'est que
grâce aux données sur la tolérance du
plasma le msm justement à éditer ce
qu'on appelle un protocole d'utilisation
thérapeutique c'est à dire qu'on peut
utiliser le plasma dans des conditions
qui sont discutées entre professionnels
dans le cas d'une réunion de
concertation pluridisciplinaire et nous
utilisons le placement actuellement dans
des circonstances particulières qui sont
celles des patients immunodéprimés
c'est à dire qu'ils n'ont pas de défense
immunitaire qui ne peuvent donc pas
avoir d'anticorps anti sarko v2 et qui
présentent des symptômes chroniques
récidivant et chez ces patients nous
avons des résultats qui sont plutôt
positifs je peux vous en parler parce
que ce n'est pas un essai thérapeutique
c'est une utilisation encadrés par là et
même du plasma alors ensuite vos trois
dernières questions celles sur les
vaccins j'espère j'aimerais que le
vaccin soit prêt en septembre parce que
si on envisage que à l'automne mélanger
à tous les autres virus rhinovirus
métapneumovirus vrs grippe etc
il y à du coc vite 19 au milieu de tout
ça et bien on va avoir beaucoup de mal à
faire la part des choses et test le test
test test va être extrêmement important
nous savons tous en france que
malheureusement il y à une hésitation
vaccinale majeur je me rappelle au tout
début de les interventions télévisées
avoir été en contact avec le public est
une des auditrices me disais mais j'ai
extrêmement peur du vaccin
j'ai créé mon peur du virus qu'est-ce
que je peux faire ce que je peux prendre
un traitement et je lui ai dit mais
madame est ce que vous êtes vacciné
contre la grippe et elle m'a regardé en
me disant d'un an contre l'ags non
pourquoi la grille mais parce qu'en fait
la grippe il ya des milliers et des
milliers de morts tous les ans et
pourtant les gens ne se vaccinent pas
contre la grippe donc j'espère que avec
cette alerte majeure du coc vide 19
eh bien ce sera un argument majeur pour
si le vaccin est disponible un jour et
pour répondre rapidement à ce que vous
disiez en termes de délais il me semble
plus raisonnable de dire un an que trois
mois et bien la majorité de la
population française se vaccine racontre
locaux vides 19
un mot rapide sur leur md y virent
puisque vous me demandiez où on était
les essais thérapeutiques il y à leur
amnésie vire qui est dans l'essai
discovery il y à un essai en france
deresmes désir contre prise en charge
standard qui est un essai international
d'ailleurs et la france et deinze et
d'inde est un des pays qui inclut des
patients pour l'instant on n'a pas de
données en termes d'efficacité sur la
morbi-mortalité sage je peux le dire
parce que les données sont publiées
le laboratoire a montré qu'il y avait un
rack ou un une rare un raccourci de la
durée d'hospitalisation mais moi en tant
que clinicienne je suis pas un financier
garder le patient cinq jours de plus à
l'hôpital
moi ça ne me gêne pas si le patient
guéri près ça peut être une question de
finances publiques de dire que cinq
jours c'est quand même mieux
voilà mais ça pour moi ça m'est
complètement égal moi ce qui m'importe
c'est savoir si la molécule un effet sur
la morbi mortalité est à ce jour que les
données qui sont publiés il n'y a pas
d'effet du remdh et y virent ce la
morbi-mortalité professeur quelques
questions très courtes très direct vous
évoquez devant nous les personnes qui
sont décédées après avoir pris de
l'hydroxyde rockin vous êtes une
professionnelle de la santé
particulièrement jaillira même vous
mener des projets de recherche
vous savez que pour faire une étude
solide de pharmacovigilance et
d'imputabilité
il faut plusieurs semaines plusieurs
mois et c'est extrêmement compliqué donc
dans ce délai bref il est impossible
d'imputer les décès des patients al
hydroxyque leur quine j'aimerais avoir
votre avis sur cette ce que je viens de
dire deuxième question avez vous dans
votre service utilisez-les hydroxy
chloroquine auprès de vos patients quel
est le taux de mortalité dans votre
service si vous pouvez nous nous
l'indiqué quels sont alors non pas
les conflits d'intérêts avec les
laboratoires mais peut-être les liens
d'intérêts notamment avec le laboratoire
gilead puisque la presse ce matin même
évoque des sommes conséquentes reçu par
ce laboratoire est peut-être d'autres
qu'avez vous fait de ces sommes et je
terminerai par là ne pensez-vous pas
parce que vous êtes une clinicienne que
moins de passion serait arrivé à
l'hôpital si les médecins généralistes
en première ligne qui sont les
cliniciens en qui les patients ont
confiance aurait pu être
j'allais dire sollicité dans des
procédures de soins et n'ait pas été
comme il malheureusement ça n'a été fait
écarter un du parcours de soins je vous
remercie
merci monsieur gautier c'est une
présidente professeur lacombe vous avez
évoqué la vitalité en france facteur
important donc on n'a pas eu de bons
résultats sur le sur le pays trente
mille morts pour cent soixante mille cas
à peu près ça nous fait des chiffres à
18%
c'est beaucoup plus que beaucoup
d'autres pays même que l'allemagne le
portugal et même que les états unis donc
on n'a pas été bon là dessus vous avez
évoqué l'importance des tests et
notamment l'importance de dépister les
asymptomatiques
évidemment ce qui n'a pas été fait au
début de l'épidémie d'où les proportions
considérables que ça a pris et parce que
des patients contagieux asymptomatique
et contagieux n'ont pas été testés on a
parlé de gilles ead d'avis tout ça ce
sont des labos l'industrie
pharmaceutique en lien avec le réel
désir lopinavir ritonavir tout
traitement potentiel molécules
candidates et alternative à
l'hydroxyethyl rockin dont vous pouvez
très bien comprendre le doute qui est
qui est semée par rapport à ces à ses
liens avec l'industrie pharmaceutique
le président du haut conseil de la santé
publique a lui même reconnu avoir subi
des pressions et avoir signé un avis qui
la qualifient d'absurde
si et quand même
un comble vous comprenez qu'il est quand
même difficile pour un conseil difficile
pour un arbitre d'être rémunéré par in
des équipes même si c'est un autre
moment même si c'est pour une autre
prestation même si c'est légitime même
si c'est légal
merci david habib je veux d'abord dire à
notre collègue julien moreau vick qui a
parlé de 2,2 possibilité pour chacun
d'entre nous d'être soumis à l'ets plus
d'être s'ouvrir à des conflits
d'intérêts non non c'est il ya des
règles il ya des règles ce n'est pas à
vous que je le dis moi sanofi à mener
dans ma commune
j'en suis très fier j'ai jamais mangé
avec un dirigeant de sanofi
voilà et la question des conflits
d'intérêts si je le dis pour notre
commission et la qualité notre
commission je crois que c'est la
confiance que l'on doit avoir dans le
travail de la présidente et du
rapporteur
c'est ça qui nous permettra d'évoluer
pour le moment nous on a à essayer de
définir ce qui s'est passé il ya une
phrase que vous avez dit qu'ils me qui
m'a interpellé vous avez dit la science
a été malmené en france immédiatement
j'ai envie de vous dire et ailleurs est
ce que c'est un débat hexagonal
comme tous les débats que la france peut
connaître sur l'éducation soit
philosophie est-ce qu'il ya quelque
chose il ya une particularité française
moi je souhaiterais que vous puissiez
nous éclairer là dessus et que l'on
essaye de comprendre parce que ce qui
est évident c'est qu'on avait tous
confiance dans le personnel médical puis
vigier vous a posé la question en vous
disant aujourd'hui on est tous il n'y a
pas que la science qui malmenés on est
tous les français malmenés parce qu'on a
vu un milieu complètement émietté
complètement et qian éclaté madame la
professeure quand vous dites il y avait
le temps médiatique mais le meilleur
moyen de résister à ce temps médiatique
c'est pas aller sur les plateaux et je
ne comprends pas qu olivier ferrand
n'est pas rappeler à un moment donné à
l'ensemble des médecins qui sont libres
mais qui ont aussi peut-être des
obligations d'éthique que ils sont mieux
dans leurs hôpitaux que
sur les chaînes de télévision je
voudrais revenir vous un point la
captation de la parole médicale aussi on
a ce sentiment là on est tous député de
province est confronté et amis souvent
avec des médecins qui étaient comme vous
l'avez indiqué face à même si dans mon
département s'était plutôt préservé mais
face en tout cas l'angoissent des des
gens il ya le sentiment dans ce pays
d'avoir deux types de médecins et je
peux sans vie de dire et pour être
provocateur
les médecins parisiens les autres ou
plus exactement les médecins des
hôpitaux parisiens et les autres pour
avoir votre sentiment là-dessus
en sachant que vous même vous faites
partie de la première catégorie
hier le professeur out a dit les centres
de recherche ne sont plus au contact du
quotidien des malades
c'est quelque chose que j'ai noté pour
avoir votre sentiment là-dessus
puis vous avez dit sur les masques sur
les tests le fait qu'un médecin de façon
presque définitive disent à la
télévision les masques ne servent à rien
et puis ensuite dit linverse s'appelle
quoi chez vous comme comment tu as fait
pas de vous un jeu s'appelle comprend
comme commentaire à la fois comme
citoyenne et comme médecin les enquêtes
de pharmacovigilance qui ont été lancés
ont débuté en mars inde et l'utilisation
de l'hydroxyde coquine et c'est vrai que
l'imputabilité et difficile à mettre
mettre en évidence vous avez raison mais
quand un médicament utilisé de façon
massive et qu'on voit augmenter un
signal sur certains effets secondaires
et en particulier le cardio vasculaires
il y a quand même non pas un lien de
causalité que c'est extrêmement
compliqué comme vous venez
de le dire mais un lien de temporalité
c'est pour ça que il y à des alertes et
les alertes ont été lancées à cette
époque là l'autre l'autre et c'est
l'essai tout court pardon qui a montré
de façon assez claire le combien
l'utilisation des drogues cycle rock et
dans le contact du coc vide 19 devait
être réfléchie s'est laissée au brésil
où l'hydroxyde chloroquine a entraîné un
taux de mortalité par causes cardiaques
supérieur chez les patients qui ont
utilisé la chloroquine versus là le
groupe standard de traitement dans cet
essai ce qui a était critiquable c'est
que la posologie l'hydroxyde chloroquine
utilisé mais je vous réponds était
élevée voyez je n'ai lu aucun problème
que peuvent poser les études donc la
posologie était élevé ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que si on revient sur cette
histoire de concentration qui de roxy
chloroquine pour qu'elle soit efficace
on l'a bien vu une vie trop on ne peut
pas l'utiliser à une posologie standard
faible on est obligé de la deûle
administré une posologie qui est assez
élevé et c'est pour ça que par exemple
dans les séries causerie le la posologie
initial était double de la posologie des
jours qui ont suivi parce qu'il faut
avoir une concentration antiviral ou
concentration de médicaments assez
important dans le sens et rapidement
pour qu'il y ait une efficacité
antivirale et c'est probablement parce
que justement on doit utiliser les de
roxy chloroquine à une posologie assez
élevé qu'il ya une augmentation du
risque cardiovasculaire sachant que
quand on utilise à une posologie faible
et bien il n'y a pas d'activité
antiviral est ce que nous avons utilisé
l'hydroxyde chloroquine dans mon service
oui bien sûr au début du mois de mars
comme dans tous les
toutes les régions qui ont été touchés
par le sarko v2 et il y a eu d'ailleurs
une enquête très intéressante de densité
d'utilisation et roxy chloroquine en
france et on voit qu'en fait là où ça a
été le plus utilisé en termes de nombre
d'habitants ce n'est pas du tout en
région paca
mais c'est dans le grand test etc
région parisienne nous avons très vite
arrêté d'utiliser les proxys chloroquine
comme nous avons arrêté d'utiliser le
lopinavir ritonavir je dirais avant la
fin du mois de mars parce qu'on a bien
vu que dans les patients qu'on avait en
face de nous il n'y avait pas
d'efficacité
en revanche nous les patients nous avons
traités étaient au nombre de quelques
centaines
or pour montrer une différence
d'efficacité entre débats traitement
c'est plusieurs plusieurs centaines de
patients qu'il faut inclure dans les
essais c'est pour ça que on a décidé de
n'utiliser les toxiques euros qui nous
le lopinavir que le cadre des essais
thérapeutiques
le taux de mortalité de l'ap-hp alors le
taux de vous le taux de mortalité pardon
dans mon service en fait taux de
mortalité dans mon service n'était pas
très élevé parce que j'ai un service de
médecine et que quand un patient a les
mains il était transféré en réanimation
donc je pense que le taux de mortalité
de mon service ne représente pas le taux
de mortalité hospitalière et vous il
vaut mieux se baser sur le taux de
mortalité hospitalière
le taux de mortalité hospitalière et aux
environs alors je n'ai pas le chiffre
exact mais aux environs de 10% me
semble-t-il
alors que dans les services de
réanimation il est beaucoup plus élevé
aux environs de 25 %
et d'ailleurs ce qui me permet de
rebondir sur ce qu'on disait par rapport
à la d'exams états zone
la raison pour laquelle nous en france
il est quasi impossible de montrer
l'efficacité la dexaméthasone c'est que
dans les séries causeries dans le bras
contrôle non dans le bras standard de
traitement les avis une mortalité de 40%
n'est jamais une mortalité que nous on a
eu dans nos services
parce que dans le bras standard de
traitement ont traité déjà nos passions
et ont traité nos passions d'une lame
avec la meilleure prise en charge qui
était disponible pour nous dont les
corticoïdes le vous me posez une
question sur mes liens d'intérêts alors
j'ai expliqué le principe des liens
d'intérêts combien il était encadré par
la loi
je ne sais pas je n'ai pas regardé les
médias ce matin ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que l'encadrement
de mes liens d'intérêts est extrêmement
stricte il n'y a pas d'enrichissement
personnel
parce que c'est ce que l'on peut
soupçonner avec les conflits d'intérêts
il n'y a pas de financement occulte la
base de transparence est là pour le
prouver
il n'y a pas non plus d'enrichissement
personnel tout le travail qui a fait
l'objet de rémunération est un travail
effectivement fait quand je prépare
juste pour vous donner un ordre d'idée
quand je prépare une conférence le
laboratoire va me demander de faire une
demi heure de conférence derrière il ya
7 heures de travail sept heures de
travail que je fais le soir que je fais
le week end quand on me demande de
participer à une réunion d'experts donc
apporter une expertise
j'ai des documents à relire un avis
intellectuelle à porter et un regard
scientifique a porté sur ces documents
c'est en général 4 à 5 heures de travail
l'a aussi fait le soir et le week-end
donc il est normal que quand on fournit
un travail on ait une rémunération à la
valeur du travail que l'on fait cette
rémunération est encadrée déclaré et en
toute transparence le alors le vous
aviez une question sur les une question
très intéressante
alors excusez moi si je n'ai pas je
pense que ça doit être vous sur les
généralistes au coeur du dispositif
c'est vous voilà et c'est une question
extrêmement intéressante et vraiment je
vous remercie de l'avoir posée parce que
je pense que c'est quelque chose qu'on
n'a pas abordé jusqu'à maintenant et
s'il ya une grande leçon à tirer de
cette crise et que la médecine générale
n'a pas été assez mises au coeur du
dispositif et je pense qu'il ya une
erreur qui a été fait mais c'est
probablement une erreur liée à l'
angoisse où on a dit oh oh oh oh
personnes malades
n'allez pas chez votre généraliste
appeler le 15 le 15 c'est retrouver
débordés ne venez pas aux urgences on va
vous rappeler que cet art etc
et là ça a été très complexe mais
pourquoi je pense là aussi il faut pas
non plus revenir sur ce fameux biais
d'histoires reconstruire l'histoire
on est entré dans une phase au moment où
ces décisions là ont été prises on était
dans une phase où
l'été on était débordé on ne savait pas
exactement comment le virus se transmet
ses on s'est dit si tout le monde se
précipite chez son médecin
alors qu'il n'y a pas de masque en
dehors de l'hôpital il va y avoir une
transmission massive du virus
et ça je pense que c'est une leçon à
tirer le généraliste évidemment on doit
être au coeur de la prise en charge des
patients dans un phénomène épidémique en
particulier quand la grosse majorité des
patients il faut le rappeler ont peu de
symptômes et donc ne doivent pas arriver
à l'hôpital et être hospitalisé
85% des personnes affectées non peu de
symptômes
alors je ne minimise pas les symptômes
ce que vous savez qu'on a maintenant une
espèce de kobe de chroniques ces
syndromes post kovy donc ça ne veut pas
dire que les gens ne sont pas malades
mais ils n'ont pas de symptômes assez
grave soit hospitalisé donc absolument
les généralistes doivent être au coeur
du dispositif vous reveniez monsieur sur
le taux de létalité les personnes
dépistées vous dites en france on a été
mauvais on n'a pas été mauvais en terme
de mortalité on a été mauvais en termes
de dépistage et vous savez que le taux
de létalité moins des pistes et bien
plus le taux de létalité est élevé quand
on regarde le taux de mortalité c'est à
dire le nombre de décès par million
d'habitants on n'est pas si mal
par exemple la belgique est très au
dessus la suède qui n'a pas confiné et
très au dessus et d'ailleurs est très
critiqué dans son pays pour ça donc je
crois qu'on est en gros au huitième rang
donc voilà c'est pas oui alors le nombre
de cas mais après on ça c'est difficile
aussi puisqu'on n'a pas été optimale et
et vous l'avez bien rappeler sur le
dépistage
donc le taux de létalité c'est le décès
par rapport au nombre de dépistages si
le nom de dépistage est peu élevée bien
évidemment le taux des qualités sera lui
élevé puisque c'est une histoire de
dénominateurs et numérateur vous me
demandiez les résultats préliminaires de
l'essai placement alors ce n'est pas 60
mais 120 patients fait que l'on doit
inclure dans cet essai 60 patients qui
bénéficient du plasma et 60 patients qui
bénéficient du standard de traitement
quand nous avons ouvert sept essais au
début du mois d'avril
eh bien nous étions déjà en phase de
décélération de l'epide
amy et vous avez probablement constater
que enfin sûrement parce que vous
connaissez aussi bien que moi la
dynamique de l'épidémie que on a eu très
rapidement et c'était une bonne chose
pour les équipes de soins une
décélération du nombre de personnes qui
sont arrivées à l'hôpital
dans un essai thérapeutique pour faire
en sorte que la population chez laquelle
on teste un médicament soit la plus
homogène possible pour qu'il n'y ait pas
de biais eh bien on a des critères
d'inclusion et beaucoup de patients qui
sont arrivés en avril quand l'essai a
été mise en place n'avait pas les
critères d'inclusion pour bénéficier de
laisser plasma donc actuellement nous
n'avons pas de résultats préliminaires
comme nous l'espérions pour fin avril ou
début mai en revanche comme je vous ai
dit tout à l'heure nous allons mettre à
disposition de mayotte et de la guyane
le plasma et j'espère qu'on pourra
répondre à la question de l'efficacité
du plasma il faut savoir qu'aux états
unis
le placement donc où l'épidémie fait
encore rage le placement a été évalué en
termes de tolérance chez plus de vingt
mille patients donc beaucoup beaucoup de
monde ont été indépendamment des essais
thérapeutiques ya beaucoup de monde au
bénéficier du plasma et le la tolérance
semble est excellente mais je ne parle
pas de je ne pars pas d'efficacité
on a beaucoup parlé des écoles huit mois
sur le modèle gris pâle on a fermé des
écoles avant même le confinement parce
qu'on pensait que les enfants et ont été
contaminées les contaminants aujourd'hui
des études semblent converger pour dire
que les enfants s'ils peuvent être
contaminés leçons d'abord par
l'entourage proche à la maison et sont
peu compte un contaminant par rapport à
cela
comment réagissez-vous par rapport à la
fermeture d'écoles là où des cas de
corne à vue risque on peut être détectée
est ce que c'est bien utile au fond de
priver les enfants de l'école alors même
qu' ils ne sont pas vecteur de la
maladie et est ce que pas pardonné le
côté profane de la question mais ce que
par rapport aux hypothèses d'une
mutation du virus
est-ce qu'il faut se préparer à une
mutation du virus qui pourraient faire
en sorte que le virus pourrait se
transformer et de faire des enfants des
personnes à la fois contaminés plus
largement et plus contaminante
merci valérie rabault oui merci madame
la présidente madame la professeure
quelques questions est ce que on a par
région le nombre
c'est très précis le numérateur nombre
de décès en réanimation divisé par le
nombre de personnes qui sont sorties de
la réanimation où le nombre total de
personnes et je parle que du coc vide
parce que professeur raoult nous a sorti
un ratio de 1 à 3 hier entre les morts
en réanimation à paris en région ile de
france est toujours en réanimation sur
ceux qui sont passés en réanimation je
suis très précises sur mon sur la
fraction deuxième question est ce que
vous avez connaissance de pénurie de
propofol sur les hôpitaux parisiens et
même plus généralement sur les hôpitaux
en général est ce que du coup vous savez
s'il ya des instructions pour ne pas
reprendre toutes les opérations
chirurgicales du fait de ces peut-être
possible pénurie de propofol
troisième question sur la recherche hier
le professeur raoul nous a indiqué que
nous ne faisons pas la course en tête
sur notamment la question des indes et
des maladies infectieuses
il a cité la chine il a cité d'autres
laboratoires est ce que vous partagez ce
constat là oui ou non
quatrième question s'il devait y avoir
une deuxième vague ce qui évidemment
personne ne souhaite ici est ce que
l'expérience qui a été tenté de dire on
déplace des malades des malades de
réanimation par des tgv etc dans des chu
des hôpitaux autres est-ce que sur le
retour d'expérience que vous pouvez en
avoir vous estimez que c'était une bonne
chose ou est ce qu'il aurait mieux valu
à mener la réanimation
à paris en tout cas dans la région
francilienne et à mulhouse plutôt que
déplacer les malades
dernier point qui n'est pas une question
mais qui a un commentaire je partage je
connais rien en médecine mais sur les
finances publiques j'ai quelques
connaissances sur l'hépatite c je
partage pas du tout le récit que vous
avez fait de ce qui s'est passé
un traitement allaient pas tissé ces
soixante sept mille euros s'il ya trois
boîtes à prendre et ça ça coûte la
bagatelle de 1 milliard d'euros à peu
près un peu plus maintenant d'ailleurs
aux finances publiques de la sécurité
sociale la négociation avec le
laboratoire américain ne s'est pas du
tout passé comme ce que vous avez dit
pas du tout ça a été un bras de fer
épouvantable ça a été un bras de fer où
la france a été certes roux est tout
seul avec les italiens l'allemagne a
fait son marché de son côté parce
qu'elle avait des excédents budgétaires
et dont je ne crois pas que quoi que ce
soit de liens qui pouvaient exister a
fait que le prix a baissé bien au
contraire un traitement ses soixante
sept mille euros et pour avoir été bien
au courant de la négociation pardon
merci oui mais bien au chaud tout départ
de la négociation en 2016 je peux vous
dire qu'il ya aucun cadeau qui a été
fait à la france
merci l'état du stock de plasma à
l'établissement français du sang donc
actuellement la collecte a été
interrompue il y a à peu près 5000
unités de placement stocker la raison
pour laquelle la collecte a été
interrompue c'est que l'épidémie a
largement largement ralenti les stocks
de plasma sont valables un an me
semble-t-il et le la procédure de
collecte de plasma pourra être réactivée
très vite si jamais nous devions faire
face à une deuxième vague
je ne me prononce pas sur le fait que
l'on n'est arrêté je ne porte pas de
jugement sur le fait que l'on ait arrêté
c'est une décision qui est revenu à le f
s peut-être qu'il faudra revenir
directement vers eux pour leur demander
pourquoi ça a été arrêté si on pense
qu'il peut y avoir une deuxième vague
une question très intéressante sur les
écoles primaires en particulier la
fermeture des écoles
effectivement nos connaissances ont
beaucoup évolué entre février mars où on
a dit et je les dis d'ailleurs personne
ne m'en a fait la remarque mais j'ai
pensé parce qu'il y avait des données
scientifiques en ce sens que les enfants
pouvaient être peu malade mais avoir
beaucoup de virus parce qu'on l'a vu
avec beaucoup d'eau d'infections virales
bien finalement l'état des connaissances
a évolué et actuellement on a des
données solides en particulier des
données françaises qui tendent à dire
que non seulement l'enfant a peu de
réplication virale mais en plus il a peu
de symptômes donc l'enfant n'est pas un
vecteur de transmission c'est plutôt les
parents qui ont contaminé leurs enfants
et les enfants plutôt été une barrière
naturelle à la progression du virus donc
la fermeture des écoles actuellement à
l'enjeu par les écoles primaires je ne
parle pas des collèges ou des lycées
parce que il a aussi été montré que
quand l'enfant devient adolescent 15 16
ans il a tendance à se comporter un peu
comme un adulte sur le plan
immunologique donc la fermeture des
écoles primaires probablement que c'est
excessif quand il y à un cas dépistés en
ce qui concerne les lycées c'est autre
chose est fermé l'intégralité d'un lycée
pour un cas dépistés c'est probablement
aussi excessif il en revanche il est
très important de dépister toutes les
personnes contactent des adolescents qui
aurait pu être dépistées
en ce qui concerne la stabilité du virus
il semblerait comme les autres
coronavirus que ce soit un virus qui
soit relativement stable au contraire de
virus respiratoires comme la grippe
donc pour l'instant on n'a pas identifié
de mutation majeure qui pourrait penser
qu' on va avoir une nouvelle maladie
plus virulente moins virulente qui va se
développer mais évidemment il faut
rester très attentifs à l'évolution des
connaissances une vous aviez une
question madame sur le nombre de décès
en réanimation par rapport au nombre de
personnes entraient en réanimation
ce chiffre est disponible mais je ne
peux pas vous le donner
en revanche je pense que au vu des
accusations d'hier il va être très
important que ce chiffre soit rendue
publique
de façon à dépassionner le débat et
ramener la réalité des chiffres
la pénurie de propofol
en gros la pénurie de médicaments
anesthésiants il y a eu mois de février
mars
parce qu'il y a eu un grand nombre de
personnes admises en animation je vous
rappelle qu'au plus fort de l'épidémie
nous étions à 7000 patients en
réanimation
la pénurie de médicaments anesthésiants
l1 pas été française elle a été mondiale
donc ce n'est pas une caractéristique ou
une défaillance du système français
c'est plutôt une défaillance mondial où
on a des en général une production quasi
à flux tendu de médicaments avec des
contrats qui sont passés pour l'achat
l'approvisionnement en médicaments
mais quand on a en l'espace de deux
semaines une demande mondiale excessive
d'un médicament on peut comprendre que
il ya les chaînes de production ne fasse
pas de puissent faire face un point qui
est très important et qui dérive de
votre question c'est que indépendamment
de la fabrication de la disponibilité
des médicaments anesthésiants en france
on sait que healy a très peu de
fabricants de médicaments en france
qu'on nous avons beaucoup de contrats
avec l'étranger et que pour des
médicaments comme des antibiotiques
absolument classique on se trouve en
rupture d'approvisionnement alors là je
sors du coc vide mais je profite pour
ramener ce point précis cette question
précise dans le débat c'est que
probablement il va falloir réfléchir
là où sont fabriqués les médicaments et
les chaînes d'approvisionnement en
médicaments
si on ne veut pas à l'avenir se
retrouver perpétuer les pénuries ou les
difficultés d'approvisionnement les
tensions d'approvisionnement qu'on peut
connaître avec certains médicaments
est ce que nous avons fait alors eh oui
oui pardon et les interventions
chirurgicales non on n'a pas alors moi
je n'ai pas du tout connaissance en même
temps je ne suis pas sûr rien y règne
matière chirurgicale mais je n'ai eu
aucune
aucun courrier vu passer aucune
instruction et pourtant tant que chef de
service je reçois toutes les
instructions de l'ap-hp où toutes les
alertes
je n'ai eu aucune alerte sur le fait
qu'on ne faisait pas de chirurgie parce
qu'on n'avait pas de médicaments
anesthésiants mais voilà je ne peux me
prononcer qu'à mon niveau de chef de
service à ce que nous faisons la course
en tête ou pas franchement la science
c'est pas c'est pas une c'est un sprint
c'est une course de fond et c'est une
course de fond où on alimente où chacun
alimente les connaissances avec son
travail moi ça ne m'importe pas de
savoir que les chinois sont premiers que
les américains sont premiers deuxièmes
que nous on est à la traîne dans les
domaine que je connais bien que ce
qu'ils sont l'hépatite c est le vih en
termes de publications scientifiques
nous sommes parmi les trios de
publications donc de production de
connaissances je pense que nous avons
pour le vih et l'hépatite c ou
l'hépatite b produit une science de
qualité de grande qualité scientifique
internationale et nous sommes nombreux à
intervenir fréquemment sur le plan
international sur ces questions de santé
donc après qu'on soit premier deuxième
franchement je ne pense pas que cette
course 2 course en tête ou pas un
intérêt alors les malades malades en
réanimation avec les tgv mais je pense
que en ile-de-france et dans le grand
est
ça nous a sauvés ça nous a sauvés c'est
à dire que une fois que les patients
étaient stabilisés ils ont été envoyés
dans les réanimations où il y avait dans
des régions il y avait beaucoup moins de
cas et ça a permis de d'abord
d'augmenter le nombre de lits déjà le
nom de lits de réanimation ont été
augmentés mais au bout d'un moment
et bien on a quand on a des capacités en
réanimation ailleurs sur le territoire
nous sommes un petit territoire en même
temps
quand on a des capacités d'animation
ailleurs sur le territoire que les
patients sont stabilisés les envoyer
ailleurs par des ponts aériens ou des
ponts ferroviaires
ça me semble avoir été une excellente
idée et en même temps nous nous avons
monté à l'échelle et j'aimerais je
reprends cette image de dominos c'est à
dire que en fonction de l'augmentation
de l'épidémie nous avons été capables
d'ouvrir des services de médecine
d'ouvrir des services de réanimation et
au final on a fait face et je pense que
c'est vraiment ça qui compte
l'élimination des baptisés écoutez je
connais bien cette cette thématique
puisque j'ai été aux côtés de médecins
du monde donc j'ai travaillé longtemps
comme bénévole pour médecins du monde
dans les pays asiatiques pour le vih et
les hépatites virales et j'ai été des
combats avec le medicines patent pool
avec médecins du monde pour l'accès aux
traitements de l'hépatite c à des prix
en particulier l'accès au générique à
des prix les plus faibles possibles et
l'accès au générique et le la casse la
cassure du monopole de gilead sur les
traitements de l'hépatite c donc vous
parler à une convaincue et je ne crois
pas dans mon discours mais je m'excuse
si ça a été le cas avoir dit que le
laboratoire était merveilleux dans tout
ce qu'il a fait voilà mais vraiment je
est actuellement le traitement de
l'hépatite c c 17 mille euros avec des
médicament d'un autre laboratoire est
bien inférieure à 40 mille euros avec
les médicaments de du laboratoire gilead
l'articulation réseau hospitalier et
structures de recherche bien oui bien
sûr c'est un c'est extrêmement important
peut-être que nous avons des efforts à
faire sur ce plan-là pourrait en
particulier
non pas tant au niveau des chu mais
travailler plus de façon plus étroite
avec les clg les clg qui sont un
maillage hospitalier indispensable sur
notre territoire national et
probablement que la recherche la
coopération de recherche avec les clg
n'est pas assez importante et je l' ai
bien vu justement avec les essais
thérapeutiques qui ont été ouverts
principalement dans les chu alors que
beaucoup de nos concitoyens ont été
prises en charge dans les ca g
donc je pense effectivement qu'il va
falloir s'améliorer sur ce plan là et
puis enfin la pénurie des médicaments
alors la pénurie des médicaments ben
j'en ai un peu parlé tout à l'heure
quand j'ai parlé des filières
d'approvisionnement et du problème de du
manufacturing de la fabrication des
médicaments sur le territoire français
est ce que à l'avenir en particulier
l'occasion d'une deuxième vague nous
aurons des pénuries de médicaments
si on estime que la deuxième vague sont
fait le parallèle avec des épidémies de
grippe la grippe de hong kong dans les
années 68 69 a duré deux ans gros est ce
que le s que nous là en l'espace de six
sept mois on va pouvoir re localiser la
fabrication des médicaments
je suis pas du tout une spécialiste de
la question mais en tant que citoyenne
ça me semble un peu compliqué mais
probablement qu'il va falloir réfléchir
à aller dans cette direction là dans les
années à venir mais je me prête je me
positionne vraiment en tant que
citoyenne si monsieur rapporteur n'a
rien à ajouter moi je là quelque chose à
ajouter
moi aussi je peux me permettre juste une
petite question ou ce qu'on a parlé il
ya combien l'équipe de chèques de
chercheurs là en ce moment si vous le
savez sur le co vide en ce moment en
france qui sont vraiment savait pas
alors je n'ai pas le chiffre exact jeu
mais je pense que je peux tout à fait le
trouver très rapidement mais je pense
que la grosse majorité des équipes de
recherche à au moins orienté une de ses
activités sur le colis 19
merci madame la présidente
une question sur la prise en charge je
suis vous étiez intervenus je crois je
prends vu dans la presse sur la question
de la prise en charge des personnes
âgées
l'hôpital et dans les services de
réanimation est ce que pour vous ça a
été une difficulté
est-ce que vous avez pris en charge des
personnes âgées notamment en provenance
des ehpad puisque ben ça sera un sujet
sur lequel notre commission sera amené à
se pencher la question du lieu de prise
en charge le plus pertinent pour éviter
une perte de risque des personnes âgées
alors je peux vous répondre à plusieurs
niveaux d'abord à mon niveau de chef de
service le l'âge médian des patients qui
ont été hospitalisés dans mon service
était supérieure à 70 ans donc je ne
sais pas à partir de quand on considère
vraiment une personne âgée enfermement
du troisième âge des 4e âge bon on a eu
des personnes très âgées 85 90 plus de
90 ans et nous n'avons refusé personne
en raison de son âge à l'hôpital les
ehpad qui avait besoin d'hospitaliser
impatients ont pu les hospitaliser par
les urgences ensuite je ne parle pas de
du choix qui a été fait dans certaines
ehpad d'envoyer ou pas leurs résidents à
l'hôpital le ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que il y a beaucoup de personnes qui ont
quitté en ehpad qui était extrêmement
dépendant pour tous les gestes de la vie
quotidienne qui était grabataire donc y
bénéficier des soins avant le coc vilain
qui bénéficiaient de soins optimaux dans
la structure dans leurs structures qui
étaient pour beaucoup avec des troubles
cognitifs très important donc en gros
langage de tous les jours c'est à dire
plus de contacts avec l'entourage et
probablement que ces personnes là n'ont
qui ont attrapé le coc vide soit par
leur famille soit par les soignants
n'ont pas été amené aux urgences parce
que la qualité de vie était déjà
détériorer et qu'il y avait aucun
bénéfice à leur faire subir une arrivée
aux urgences une hospitalisation dans un
secteur de médecine parce que même si
ces personnes avaient des troubles
cognitifs importants et est grabataire
et n'avait pas toute leur tête la
douleur physique chez quelqu'un qui est
grabataire et qu'il n'a pas de contacts
ne peut pas être mesurée mais elle est
probablement là donc dans les soins que
l'on porte à une personne on ça doit
toujours être proportionnée par rapport
à l'état de cette personne ensuite c'est
beaucoup il ya eu une grande discussion
éthique autour de passage en réanimation
ou pas ce que je veux redire ici c'est
que tout passage en réanimation
indépendamment du coc vie de 19 est une
décision qui se prend en fonction de
l'état du patient du bénéfice dont on
pense qu'il peut tirer de la réanimation
avec les médecins qui sont docu plairait
animateurs et la famille je ne il n'y a
pas eu à ma connaissance d'instructions
formelles ni de décision informelle de
ne pas faire passer de personnes âgées
en réanimation uniquement au titre
qu'elle était âgée les décisions qui ont
été prises par exemple et dans mon
service a été le cas pour certains
patients que l'on n'a pas envoyé en
réanimation mais qui ont bénéficié de
soins palliatifs par une équipe de soins
palliatifs qui étaient appuyés par une
cellule éthique etc ça tout le temps été
dans le cadre de discussions collégiale
entre nous les médecins les réanimateurs
les personnes et soins palliatifs les
patients quand ils pouvaient exprimer
leur désir et la famille et un passage
aux animations
c'est pas simplement un tube qu'on nous
met dans la trachée avec de l'oxygène
c'est une s'éteint c'est un contexte
extrêmement angoissant sa demande
d'avoir des ressources physiques très
importante en termes de métabolisme et
une personne âgée très diminuée et bien
n'a pas les ressources métabolique pour
faire face séjour en réanimation est
donc envoyé quelqu'un à l'animation
qu'ils soient intubé et ventilé dans des
conditions d'angoise extrême pour au
final quand on sait que dans peut-être
100 % des cas il va décéder vient
probablement qu'il vaut mieux lui
apporter les soins de confort aux petits
mots qu'on peut mettre en place dans une
structure de soins palliatifs bien je
pense qu'on peut tous vous remercier
professeurs pour la clarté de vos
réponses et surtout la précision
merci beaucoup c'était donc l'audition
de karine lacombe chef de service des
maladies infectieuses à l'hôpital
saint-antoine de paris opposé au
professeur didier rahout pendant la
crise sanitaire sur le traitement à
l'hydroxyethyl elle s'est défendue et a
déploré je cite des controverses
hasardeuse et des polémiques stériles
cette audition et toutes celles de la
commission denquête sont à revivre cet
été sur lcp et sur notre site internet
lcp point fr